the thing I want to talk about in this
brief intro is cognate I is making
things smarter I use this word obscure
word because smart if I smarting there's
no we don't have a good verb for making
things smarter but that's what we're
doing we're we're taking everything and
we're making it smarter and we're taking
making some dumb things a little smart
and we're taking some smart things and
making them much smarter that process is
ongoing and if you make a transistor if
you make a logic gate once you have that
you wouldn't have never we make things
smarter and smarter and smarter so we're
moving in the direction where this AI
stuff is coming and we don't really have
much choice if we keep making technology
about it getting smarter and smarter but
we do have a lot of choice about how we
make it smart and you know what we do
with it the specifics so I think AI is
once is it's pretty inevitable once
you've made these kinds of things and
the proof of course is that it's already
here
you
[Music]